Now, we're taking up exactly where we left off the last day, and Louisa says, "Then
after the confessor went away and I was free, I went back to the state as before."
And so it happened that I spent sometimes a week, sometimes 15 days, and even months
being surprised by that state.
That means suddenly going into ecstasy.
Weeks and months at it, imagine.
Look at the level of holiness she has.
And then during the day, and I was able to free myself by myself, now, freeing her from
coming out of the ecstasy is now a big issue for everybody, not just for Louisa.
But when I was discovered, very often, as I said before, my family would call the confessor.
Also, since they had seen, at the first time I had been freed, while everyone believed
that I would never again recover from that state, in other words, they've all got to
get used to Louisa going into ecstasy.
But then I went down to church and I returned to that state again.
And so they would call the confessor and I would be freed.
However, I would never have imagined that it would take the priest to free me from such
a state or that my trouble was an extraordinary thing.
Now, what she's calling her trouble is an ecstasy.
Nobody considers her having an absolutely extraordinary experience yet, but they will.
And she is sometimes at this particular stage able to come out of it herself.
Sometimes she isn't.
Now, she's going to go into a stage where she can't come out of it.
And it's going to be a huge trial for her.
But what the Lord is actually doing, and I want to say this ahead of time so that it
will read normally when we're reading it, what the Lord is doing is forcing the church
to get involved.
The church is not going to get involved too easily.
The church will say, "I sure we have loads of people claiming to have visions and all
kinds of stuff."
And the church can be very blasé about it, you know what I mean?
But the Lord's going to force the church to get involved.
In other words, force the church to actually have to get this woman out of the ecstasy.
And they only have to bless her to do it.
But in other words, they have to witness her in ecstasy every single day.
And eventually it'll dawn on that this is not usual.
This is not normal.
This is totally extraordinary.
And gradually because they have to minister to her, they will eventually realize that there's
something going on in this ecstasy that she's not telling us about.
In fact, she hasn't told anybody anything yet.
And finally the priest will, as we would say, the penny will drop and he will say to her,
"You must write everything down."
Now you will realize the reason why this has been given as continuous text is that they
left her in this condition for years without even bothering to say to her, "Why don't you
write down what's happening?"
And that's why this is distant memory.
You have to get to the end of volume one before you will get the text and the date because
she'll be writing it on the day she got it.
And this is why this is all distant memory for her.
And so this is the drama that's going on at the moment.
So she said, "It's true that when I would lose consciousness or going to ecstasy that
I could see Jesus Christ, but I attributed this to the goodness of the Lord.
And when the priest sets her free, she considers it the goodness of the priest involved.
But she doesn't see that either has anything to do with herself.
She is a most extraordinarily unselfish human being.
Let me put this out of the way.
Excuse me.
So I would never have imagined it would take the priest to free me from such a state or
that my trouble was an extraordinary thing.
It's true that when I would lose consciousness I would see Jesus, but then she attributed
that to the Lord, the goodness of the Lord.
See how good the Lord is with me, that he comes to give me strength in my state of sufferings.
Otherwise, how could I sustain it?
Who would give me the strength?
It is also true that when such a state was going to occur in the morning during communion.
Now why would it happen during communion?
Isn't it because she's receiving Jesus' body, blood, soul and divinity?
Also going into an ecstatic state with him, that is the normal thing that would happen.
He would tell me that during that very state sufferings would come to me from the Lord
himself.
And my book says him himself, that's not good English, but I would pay no attention to any
of this.
Look at her, extraordinary detachment from what's actually happening to her.
Now, most people are not like that, nowadays people write books if they see an angel.
And that's not the Lord, that's millions of miles away from the Lord.
And here's a woman who is having extraordinary experience and she's saying, "No, no, I won't
pay attention to that."
The mere thought sometimes of telling the Confessor, I felt I was the proudest soul that existed
in the world.
If I dare to open my mouth to speak of these things, in other words, she thought it was
pride to speak about this extraordinary thing, but we've all personally met people who boast
about having heard a word from the Lord or a vision or even if it wasn't a proper vision,
it's only a picture.
And they boast about having absolutely minor things and here she's having major stuff and
is literally unable to say it to anybody out of humility, isn't that amazing?
When I'd feel such blushing, she said, "That is impossible to say anything to that Confessor,
no matter how good or holy he was."
It's so true that I did not think that it would take the priest to free me and that this
was happening because of the sanctity of my Confessor, that when the time came that he
went away to the countryside one morning after communion, the Lord made me understand that
I was going to be surprised by that state, inviting me to keep him company and participating
in his pains.
This is all introduction to her ministry, so she gets a little bit of suffering, she gets
a little bit of everything and gradually then he will ask her, "Will she commit herself?"
And Louisa said, "Lord, how can I do it?
The Confessor is not here, who's going to free me.
Maybe you want me to die now."
Her gracious desire was to die and you have to be able to explain that.
Some people want to die to get rid of pain.
Some people want to die just because they've had financial loss or whatever it is, all
the wrong reasons.
But if a person has had ecstatic experiences, they've seen the Lord.
They have somehow experienced heaven.
So the wanting to die is, ecstasy means the soul going out to meet the Lord, hence they're
no longer available in the body.
And the wanting to die is that you want to go completely to the Lord.
The reason why the Lord has told us all that we must live by faith and not by sight is
that we being much weaker human beings than a person like Louisa, if we had such a vision,
we would just die of the ecstasy.
Your soul would just say, "I don't know, I'm not coming, can I see it?"
I'm going, "If this is what heaven's like, then goodbye earth."
And because he wants us to live the fullness of our existence on the earth, he wants you
to complete your journey, he won't give you that vision.
It's not because he doesn't love you, it's that he wants you to have all the merits of
everything, of all your decisions in your lifetime.
So that's why he said to Thomas, "Blessed are those who have not seen and have believed."
It's actually quite important.
So the Lord just said, "Your trust must be only in me.
He resigned because resignation renders the soul radiant and it keeps all other passions
in place."
The word that is used for passions here covers all our emotions.
In such a way that attracted by those rays of light, I go to that soul and I transform
her completely within me and I give her life from my own life.
So the first stage in the journey into the divine will is to be resigned to the divine
will, the very first stage.
And Jesus says here that that makes a soul radiant, someone who's not resigned is someone
who's disturbed and upset and they have all the consequences of that disturbance.
So Louisa said, "I resigned myself to his holy will."
So this is step one and I offered that communion as the last one in my life, the poor girl,
she has 36 volumes to go.
I should say 35 since this is the first one.
But though resigned, I felt my nature very much.
This is just awkward English.
It means that even though you resign yourself to the will of God, it doesn't take the pain
away.
But for the whole day, I did nothing but cry and pray the Lord to give me strength.
Now she's still a teenager and tears are easy.
In truth, that situation turned out to be so very bitter for me and without thinking
or knowing anything, I found myself with a new and heavy cross to Corinthians 12.8.
So while I was in that stage of suffering, I would think of nothing but dying and doing
the will of God.
But as for my family, they also suffered in seeing me in that stage.
Try and imagine yourself, the parent of a teenager who's spending hours and hours and
hours in her room all by herself, no matter what, even if she is claiming to be praying
and all the rest of it, and not out there socializing or doing the ordinary things that
teenagers do.
Wouldn't you be sick with worry?
Yeah, have pity on her parents.
And they know nothing.
She has told them nothing.
That's the extraordinary thing.
So they also suffered in seeing me in that stage and they tried to call some priests.
But for one reason or other, they didn't want to come.
After 10 days, he's underlined it.
This crisis went on for 10 days.
All her trials are huge.
After 10 days, the confessor came who used to confess me when I was a child.
And it happened that he, too, was able to make me come around from that stage.
Then I realized the net that the Lord had thrown over her, okay?
So the Lord wants the church to be involved.
Now, you know that there's an expression in St. Paul about a thorn in the side.
You know that one?
And he said he earnestly prayed to the Lord three times to have it removed.
And the Lord said, "No, my power is at best in weakness."
Now, the thorn in Louise's side for at least four to five volumes, if not even more, is
that the priest has to come to set her free.
And she begs the Lord not three times like St. Paul, but more than 33.
She keeps on asking the Lord to take this way.
She finds this extremely humiliating.
And that's why, again, I say to you that while she's willing to take sufferings that
the Lord will send to her, the cross she has is that thorn in her side.
So from here, a war arose against me on the part of priests, which is going to have terrible
humiliation from priests because initially the priests just think this is a fussy teenager
wanting a priest to waste his time to come to this house and bless her.
And then apparently she's okay.
So as far as they're concerned, it's all in the head.
Now, you can have sympathy for them as well.
They don't actually know what's going on and she hasn't told anybody.
So they're working in the dark, so you don't give a heavy criticism to them.
They don't know what's going on.
Some would say that it was a pretense and some that beating was needed because in those
days it could beat kids, you know.
Some that I wanted to make myself believed a saint.
Some would add that I was possessed and many other things, my goodness, that's not easy
to take, is it?
And if I tell them all the story would be too long.
So with these ideas in their minds, when sufferings would occur and my family would call one
of them, they would have such strange reactions that my poor family suffered very much, especially
my poor mother, sorry, I don't do the Italian memo a bit.
How many tears she shed for me?
Now, it would be a terrible humiliation for a family to have priests coming in and saying
all this stuff about your daughter, wouldn't it?
So the family is suffering as well.
"O Lord, reward her, you yourself," she said.
"O my good Lord, how much I suffered on this side, you alone know everything."
So who can tell how bitter this situation was for me that the priest was needed in order
to free me from that state of sufferings?
How many times I prayed shedding most bitter tears that he would free me?
So put your two Corinthians 12, 9 there, no, sorry, my power is at best in weakness, two
Corinthians 12, 9.
How many times I made explicit resistance to the Lord, Romans 9, 19, Romans 9, 19.
When he wanted to offer myself, he wanted me to offer myself as victim and accept the
pains.
So the vocation has begun, but she has to have time to really consider it.
I would say to him, "Lord, promise me that you yourself will free me and then I'll accept
everything.
Otherwise, no, I won't accept."
And I would resist the first day, the second and the third, but who can resist God?
That's your Romans 9 again.
He would tell me so many things that in the end I was forced to submit myself to the cross.
Other times I would say to him from the heart and with familiarity, "Lord, how is it that
you have done this?"
Between you and me, you now want to place a third person.
In other words, in a marriage you don't want a third person, do you?
No.
A marriage is a very private thing.
And a marriage between the soul and God is so private that if they, I'm talking about
marriage and I'm not talking about an early stage in the spiritual, I haven't talked about
the spiritual marriage.
It's so private that that person doesn't want anybody else, and that's the position
that Louis is in.
So why would you want to place a third?
That's the priest.
And this third does not even want to make himself available.
See, we could have been so content, just the two of us.
When you wanted me to suffer, I would immediately accept because I would know that you yourself
would free me.
And there's no need for another hand there.
I beg you, free me, and both of us will be more content.
But of course, she doesn't know what he's doing, and she's not going to be told until
very, very much later.
Sometimes he pretended not to hear me.
Have you ever had a relationship with a human being?
I call that switching on your deaf ear.
And he wouldn't tell me anything.
At other times he would say, "Do not fear, I am the one who gives darkness and light."
That means trials and blessings.
The time of light will come.
It's my usual way to manifest my works through the priests.
Now, there is the first statement for Louisa.
The church must be involved.
This is going to be a public revelation.
It's not going to be just a private thing between herself and Jesus.
And therefore, the church has to be involved from the beginning, and the church will do
it very reluctantly, very reluctantly.
But those of us who are up at Volume 7, we have the bishop ordering the priest not to
let visitors disturb Louisa to give her full time with the Lord.
So they've shifted and understood the importance of what's actually going on.
So Louisa said, "I spent three or four years of these contradictions on the part of priests."
That's not funny, is it?
Two or four years.
Many times they would subject me to very hard trials.
Thank God you didn't tell us.
They would reach the point of letting me remain in that state of sufferings.
That is, listen to this, petrified, incapable of the slightest motion, even of taking a
drop of water for up to eighteen days.
The priest did that, "Surely they knew she had to eat and drink to live."
Isn't that amazing?
The Lord alone knows what I was going through in that state, and after they came, I would
not even have the good of hearing them say to me, "Have patience and do the will of
God."
Rather, I was reproached for being fussy and disobedient.
In other words, she wasn't minding herself, "Oh God, what pain, how many tears I shed.
How many times I thought I was disobedient, saying to myself, 'How can this be that virtue
which is most pleasing to the Lord is so far from me?'
Now, we're going to hear a lot about obedience, so I won't give it to you now, because Louisa
has to mirror Jesus' own obedience, and I'll give you all the references for that, but
not now.
What could can a disobedient soul ever do or hope for?
Because disobedience means you're not doing the will of God.
And the whole issue in everything to do with Louisa is doing the will of God, and doing
it fully and completely and sacrificially and lovingly.
Many times I would lament to our Lord, and at times I reached the point of being resentful.
I think it's very interesting.
If you read, I think it is the book of Sirak, or Ecclesiasticus, and I think it's chapter
37, and it should be the first five verses, it'll tell you that resentment is a foul thing
and found only with sinners.
So look carefully at what she said, that I would reach the point of being resentful,
but she's not going to let it happen.
The mistake people make who are very early in the spiritual life is that they will nurse
a grudge against another person, that means that they have accepted the resentment and
they're minding it inside, and therefore destroying the relationship with the other person.
Whereas forgiveness actually releases the grudge or the resentment.
And when he wanted me to accept sufferings, I would resist as much as I could.
But when he saw that I would begin to resist, the Lord showed me that he would not pay attention
to me and that he would not tell me anything else.
He has the most wonderful way of dealing with her.
If you want this, then you're going to hear no more messages from me.
I'm not going to share anything with you.
So you won't get the divine word.
But do you know that when we are disobedient to the will of God, the Bible closes to us.
The Bible is closed to so many people because they're in disobedience to the Lord.
And there are others who are living in union with God, and the Bible reads like a newspaper.
We just need to know that the word of God is not thrown to Swine, excuse me, but he used
that example himself.
Swine are only interested in their own food.
They're not interested in pearls, and they're not interested in precious things.
And there are so many people who are so caught up with themselves and their own passions
and their own feelings.
They don't really care about the great issues of the spiritual life, which is the divine
will and loving God and your neighbor.
They don't really care about it.
And so the word of God won't be open to them.
It's actually quite important to say that.
That's why he says, you know, you won't hear the word of God.
I won't tell you anything else.
And then all of a sudden he would come to surprise me.
As for what the Confessor said, that's because sometimes he did not want me to fall into
that state, but this was not in my power.
So here you have the priest trying to say to Louisa, you don't have to go into this
ecstatic state.
You can always stay outside.
But if the Confessor had studied enough of the mystics, he would know that what he said
was nonsense because most of the mystics have had the experience that they were drawn
into ecstasy and there was no way you could resist it because it's God drawing the soul.
Nobody can resist God.
And it'll take them a while, meaning years, to realize that they cannot order God and
they cannot order this experience.
God is free to do it.
He wants.
Yes, it is true that I've been disobedient.
In other words, she's caught between the Lord and the Confessor ordering her to stay out
of ecstasy, which she can't do because the Lord is stronger than her and that I've always
been good for nothing.
But I also remember that the most tormenting pain was not being able to obey.
If Louisa is to be canonized, she could be canonized for many things, but she could be
canonized for this alone that she lived obedience at such a heroic level at a time when disobedience
became very strong in the church.
Disobedience.
I won't go into that in detail.
We can discuss it later if you want.
So the Lord has her living obedience to make reparation for the disobedience that's actually
in the church.
I remember that during this period of time, there was the cholera, and one day I prayed
my good Jesus to make this scourge cease.
And he said to me, "I will content you as long as you accept offering yourself to suffer
whatever I want."
In other words, there's the second invitation to be a victim's soul.
And Louisa said to him, "Lord, no, I cannot.
You know how they think they are the priests."
And I want you to put Galatians 1-10 there.
If this thing could pass only between you and me, I would be absolutely ready to accept
everything.
And he said to me, "My daughter, if I had thought of what men were thinking and of what
they were going to do to me, I could not have operated the redemption of mankind."
In other words, he's saying to her, "If you're thinking of what other people are thinking
of you, she wouldn't do anything.
You know, I mean, if they've nothing against you, they'll make it up.
You've never experienced that, have you?
I have."
And that's exactly what they did to Jesus.
They actually made up sins to accuse them of.
Yeah, they actually made it up.
And if people have a grudge against you for whatever reason they have, they'll decide
you're blah, blah, blah, whether you are or not.
And that's what's going on in their heads.
And Jesus says, "If you are going to govern your life with what other people are doing
in their heads, you'll never do anything."
Never.
You've got to go through the storm and you've got to take the battering of the winds.
So we're now dealing with the subject of handling opposition.
Very good for us.
Put it in the heading there, dealing with opposition on that paragraph.
So whenever I can, I'll give you a heading for a paragraph because it breaks up the text
for you.
So Louisa said, "No."
He said, "Then I couldn't operate redemption if I was thinking about what they were doing
in their heads.
But I had my eyes fixed on their salvation, and the great love that devoured me."
Now beside that before I even move on, I want you to put Hebrews 12-2, Hebrews 12-2.
That is, for the joy that was set before him, he endured the cross despising the shame.
In other words, he kept his eyes on the goal.
If you think of someone who wants to be a pilot, they won't think of all the trouble
they have to go through to get there, they'll think of the fact that one day I'll take a
plane off the ground and I'll be running that machine.
That's what they keep the goal on.
If you think of a couple getting married, the day of the marriage is absolutely wonderful,
but the hassle for a year and a half before it is unbelievable and everything that has
to be organised and things that can go wrong and have to change, they don't think of any
of that.
All they think of is that's the day we're getting married.
That's what Jesus is saying to her.
If you think of the goal, you don't think of the preparation that leads up to it.
And he's going to show us this as we go along in the writings, that if we would only keep
our eyes on Jesus and accomplishing the will of God, everything is fine.
When I would see people who were thinking ill about me, Jesus said, and who caused occasion
to make me suffer more, I would offer those very pains that they gave me for their own
salvation.
That's a major revelation at this particular point, major revelation, that not only do
you not react negatively to the people who are causing you pain, but you take it and
you in the divine will, you offer it in reparation for those very people.
So I want to give you Matthew 5, 43 to 48, Matthew 5, 43 to 48.
He starts off by saying, "I want you to be perfect like your heavenly Father."
And Matthew 5, 11 to 12.
And I also want to give you Proverbs 25, 22, Proverbs 25, 22.
Now, have you forgotten, Jesus said, that what I want from you is the imitation of my life.
Now, you're getting a description of her vocation.
And that I will make you share in everything I suffered.
Don't you know that the most beautiful act, the most heroic and the most pleasing to me,
which you must offer to me is that of offering yourself for the very ones who are against
you.
In other words, that's what Jesus did, that's what you're to do.
So that's Luke 6, 12 and following, Luke 6, 12 and following.
So Louisa said, "I remained mute."
In other words, there was nothing to say, do you know?
I didn't know what to answer.
I accepted everything the Lord wanted.
And so in the evening, I was surprised by that state of suffering.
And I remained in it for three consecutive days.
That means no food and no water for three days.
Just so you understand the consequences.
And after I came round, I no longer heard anything about the cholera.
Isn't that interesting?
So she has now been given her first taste of the power of suffering for others.
After this, I received another mortification.
And this was having to change confessor because since he was a religious, he was called back
to the convent.
I love the way referring to the men's monastery as a convent.
I was content with him and most of the Dins mentioned above, which occurred when he was
in the countryside.
Now, the Dins are all the opposition that other priests who have to fill in for him and don't
want to fill in.
And they're not interested in this woman who seems to be very strange to them.
And she said all of that would happen when this priest was away in the countryside, especially
during the last year when he was my confessor.
Because of the cholera spreading in town, he spent only six months here.
My confessor did not give many reproaches.
He would let me remain in that state of sufferings for one day, and then he would come round.
So it was less than a month since he had withdrawn to the countryside, and it became
known that he was leaving.
This was painful for me.
Not because I was attached, but because of the necessity I had for him.
So I went to the Lord and I told him of my pain, and I said to him, "I do not want you
to..."
He said, "You do not...
I do not want you to afflict yourself because of this.
I am the master of hearts, and I can turn them and turn them again if I please."
Now, that's Romans 9, 14 to 18.
Romans 9, 14 to 18.
If he did some good for you, it has been nothing but a vessel which he received from
me and gave to you, that's Acts 9, 5.
So I will do it with others, Psalm 27, 1.
Why do you fear?
The Lord is my light and my salvation.
Why should I fear?
My dear...
Look at...
You're going to have some lovely endearments between the two of them, but when you get
Louisa calling him my dear, that's when it gets funny.
As long as you keep turning your eye now to the right, then to the left, and you set
it on something now and then on something else and you don't have your eye fixed on me,
you will not be able to walk speedily on the way to heaven.
Let me give you that in plain English.
He says, "If you're looking at everybody else and what they're doing and what they're
not doing and the consequences of that, if A moves and B doesn't have blah, blah, blah,"
he says, "You're not going anywhere."
But he said, "If you want to walk quickly on the way to heaven, keep your eyes on me."
And that piece of information is for everybody.
And it has been the motto of most of the saints, "All eyes on Jesus."
That's quite literally their motto, "All eyes on Jesus."
On the contrary, you will always be limping and you will not be able to follow the influence
of grace.
Therefore, I want you to look at all things that surround you with holy indifference,
remaining all intent on me alone.
So I put Psalm 62 beside that, "Rest in God, my soul, from him comes my strength."
I'm like a tottering wall and a tumbling fence, but rest in God, my soul, he is my strength.
So after these words, my heart acquired so much strength that I suffered little or nothing
from such a great loss.
In other words, the beautiful thing about Louisa is that when the Lord tells her something,
she actually does it.
In doing it, she realizes the extraordinary wisdom with which she is being guided.
And so there's another text that you have to put over, the whole thing, rather than
any one particular thing.
And that is Deuteronomy 32, 15, Deuteronomy 32, 15.
And Deuteronomy says, "The Lord alone was her guide."
And so she's been guided by divine wisdom.
And as soon as she does what the Lord asks her to do, she immediately sees that this was
the correct thing to do and she grows.
So it happened that I changed Confessor and I returned to the Confessor who used to confess
me when I was little.
Now she doesn't realize this is going to be an extraordinary grace for her because he'll
be the first person she actually confides in.
But may the Lord be always blessed who uses those very paths which appear to be contrary
to us.
Now do you see it?
It seemed as if it was the wrong thing to do.
It was actually the right thing.
Almost as if they were to harm the soul but it's for our greater good and for his glory.
And so it happened that I began to open my soul.
This is the very first time she tells anybody what's going on.
So it's a major step forward for her a new stage in her life.
And so up to that time I had not said anything to anyone pity her parents and everybody else.
They were supposed to know what to do without knowing what was going on.
And Louisa couldn't see that that wasn't exactly just.
As much effort as I would make over myself I just couldn't do it, she said.
Even more I would see myself more impotent to tell of the things of my interior.
The blushing I felt at the mere thought of telling these things was such that I felt
it would have been easier for me to tell the ugliest sins.
When this where this came from I don't know.
It actually comes from a very deep humility and she doesn't realize it.
From the confessor I don't think so because he was so good, trustful, sweet, patient and
listening.
He would take a most exact care of my soul.
He would have his eye on everything so that I might walk straight.
For me I don't think so either because I felt a block over my soul.
Now that's the bit you need to mark.
In other words this was the time to open her soul.
It wasn't the time before now and that's the block.
That's very interesting isn't it?
And I had all the will to free myself and to hear at least what the confessor thought
about it but I felt it was impossible for me to do it.
To me I think this was an intervention of the Lord and she's very good at discerning.
This was God's Kairas time for intervention.
So finding myself with a new confessor I began to open my interior little by little.
Many times the Lord commanded me to manifest to the confessor what he had told me and when
I wouldn't do it the Lord would scold me and would reproach me severely.
So notice that it is God's time and it was this priest that the Lord wanted her to open
up to because she got no scolding in not telling anybody else.
So she gets the scolding now meaning this is the time go and do it.
And at time he reached the point of telling me that I didn't do it he would come no more
and that's the best way to treat her.
I won't come back which is the most bitter pain for me such that all others pains compared
to this seem to be nothing but blades of straw.
Therefore the fear that he really would not come was so great that I did as much as I
could in order to manifest my interior.
Now look at the level of stimulus she needed to be able to do it.
It's true that many times this costs me very much but the fear of losing my dear Jesus
would make me overcome everything.
Now I want to make a big jump to Volume 7 where one of her confessors, not this one, one
of her confessors had died and when she went into an ecstasy she saw him because she sees
souls and purgatory and everybody and she sees saints in heaven as well and he's obviously
not in heaven he's in purgatory and he said to her oh will you tell me again what Jesus
is saying to you, he said I lived on what Jesus was saying to you.
She had no idea that she was feeding them and turning them into saints, no idea at all
and it's the most wonderful dialogue between the two of them and he told her that he was
obviously in a very high place in purgatory, he was only in excuse me in for a visit if
you know what I mean and he said that all the people around him were all benefiting from
all the acts in the divine will that he did and he said I'm showing or manifesting stars
to them and she's, Louise is not a bit shy when she's in and out of the body experience
and she said well show me then and so he opened his breast and so far as you can if
you're a spirit and she saw all these stars flowing out and going out to all the other
souls in parchae and he said they're all benefiting Dholas, so he said give me another
one today so that I can cherish with them, isn't that beautiful, that's why I just wanted
to jump here and give you a taste of what's coming because she's going to have an absolutely
incredible effect on the priests who actually are guiding her.
So I know where I stopped and I was also pushed by the confessor, thank you to say where such
a state was coming from, so this is the first time the confessor now is asking for discernment
and what happened to me when I was in that state of doziness which is ecstasy, what was
the cause of it, he would then command me to manifest it and force me through the precepts
of obedience and also place before me the fear that I might be living in illusion and
deceit, living within myself while if I manifested it to the priest I would be more certain and
tranquil.
So the priest is now learning that he must pull this out of her so that real discernment
can be made and Louise doesn't realize that the priests go to the bishop and say this
is what's going on, this is what this woman is experiencing so that there's more discernment
and in no time at all it got to the Vatican because she wasn't living that far away.
So that's what the Lord had wanted was to get the church involved right up to the very
top.
So because the Lord never permits that the priest be mistaken when the soul is obedient,
look at that for a statement, that is a priest giving spiritual direction to a soul.
So Jesus Christ pushed me from one side and the confessor from the other and it seemed
to me that sometimes they were banding together, the two of them, the confessor and Jesus.
And so I managed to manifest my soul.
The past confessor couldn't do that.
He would not ask me a question, you see, so the Lord couldn't use him then for discernment.
He would not try to know what was happening to me in that state of doziness and so I myself
did not know how to come out and talk about these things.
Now saints who have had these very profound experiences have all needed somebody else
to pull it out of them because they're so caught up in what actually happened.
They can't just objectively talk about it and so somebody pulling it out of them enables
them to actually see it and discern it and appreciate it.
So the concern he had that the last confessor was that I would be resigned and conformed
to the will of God bearing the cross that the Lord had given to me.
So much so that if sometimes he saw me a little bothered, he would suffer great sorrow.
Isn't that interesting?
He would suffer sorrow but he wouldn't see anything to her.
Isn't that amazing?
In other words that he appreciated what was going on but he didn't want to penetrate
into the mystery and so what happened that I spent about another year with this confessor
in the same state described above so revealing her soul.
And since the confessor knew where the state of sufferings was coming from, he told me
that Jesus wanted me to have sufferings and that I should go to him, oh yes if Jesus wanted
sufferings, she was to go to the priest and ask for an obedience.
I remember that one morning after communion the Lord told me, daughter, the iniquities
that are committed are so many that the scale of my justice is about to overflow.
Now she is beginning a process that continues for most of her life and that is that the
Lord will tell her the condition of the church and the condition of humanity and the reason
why wars will come and the reason why chastisements have to come.
So beside that I want you to put Amos 3-7, Amos 3-7 says that the Lord never does anything
without revealing it to the prophets first.
And you see as you go along here if you were looking at this as someone trying to discern
this person you say, yes there's another sign, there's another sign, there's another sign
and the prophetic part of it is one of the signs of an authentic relationship with God.
So that I will pour heavy scourges upon men especially a most fierce war, now the most
fierce war can you guess, World War I was supposed to be the war that to end all wars
is now what they said and it didn't end anything, a most fierce war.
Now in the Old Testament war is always a punishment from God, meet it out by human beings but
a punishment from God.
So a most fierce war then would be a punishment, we've had two major ones in the 20th century.
So a most fierce war in which I will make a slaughter of human flesh, at least 70 million
people died in World War I, that's a mighty slaughter.
He continued almost crying, I gave bodies to men that they might be as many sanctuaries
where I would go to delight in them, that's going to be explained more and more and more
as you go on in the volumes, that we were created for God, he made us like him so that
he could come and dwell in us on the earth and that's why Genesis 3 says that God walked
with Adam and the cool of the day and that Proverbs 831 says that God delights to be
in the company of human beings.
So there were meant to be many sanctuaries where I would go to delight in them but they've
turned out to be sewers of rot which emanate such stench as to force me to stay far away
from them.
Okay so this is volume one, I need to explain something and it'll fit all the other volumes
as well.
If you just look at me for a minute, I need to raise my hands, I'm saying this in words
because it's going on to this, I'm going to raise my hands, this is sin rising up from
the earth and it goes up to God but nothing unholy or unworthy can ever enter the presence
of God, that's Hebrews 1214, so the sins are sent back to us as chastisement, so look
at it as a fountain, we actually create the chastisement and he will explain that in great
detail as we go on but to put a little smile on it, if you can put smile on chastisements,
I say that the Lord has a post office up there and it says return to sender, we're not having
this up here, this doesn't belong to paradise, this stinks, we're not having it, send it
back and so you'll come to realize that chastisement is something you bring on yourself, we even
use that language ourselves, we say that man is his own worst enemy, don't we, he's bringing
on the trouble on himself or that woman is our own worst enemy or whatever or that child's
going to have trouble if he or she continues like that and what we're saying is that the
actions that they're doing and the decisions they're making are going to bring terrible
trouble on them and they do and that's the meaning of chastisement but you'll hear an
awful lot about chastisement in these writings, chastisement is a severe mercy, chastisement
isn't judgment, judgment is a different thing to chastisement, World War I was a judgment,
World War II is another one and they fit very well the two waves of trouble that you hear
of in the book of Revelation and there's a third one coming, if you think there's going
to be a third world war then you're not discerning anything, so the Lord tells her that there's
human, the human race has become sewers of rot and emanate such a stench as to force
me to stay far away from them, now the greatest punishment that God can give and I'm not going
to go into this one now is to withdraw his presence because God will not be around where
stink is and if I say that then you know automatically that every moment of Jesus' life on this
earth was pure agony for him because he could see everybody's sin, he could see their wrong
motivations, he could know exactly what the enemies were thinking and saying about them
and plotting against him and everything and he had come to shed his blood to save these
people so it must have been unbelievable, you know it must have been like walking in
the sewers to use his own language here, see what a recompense I receive for so much love
and for so many pains that I have suffered for them, who has ever been treated like me,
he said no one, but what is the cause, it's the excessive love that I have for them, do
you remember that statement, Isaiah 53 I think it is, he was hated without cause, therefore
I will try to get through to them with chastisements, you see my book says I will try with chastisements,
you need to add the words get through to them, I will try and break through to them with
chastisements, do you see that, yeah, so the book says I will try with chastisements but
it means I will try to get through to them with chastisements, so Louise's response was
she said that her heart split with pain, it seemed to me that the offenses that they
were giving him were so many that in order to escape he wanted to hide within me almost
to find a refuge, now you'll understand that much better in the higher volumes when each
one of us goes into the divine will and he makes each one of us a sanctuary and he can
live on the earth in us, why because we're doing the divine will and so he finds a home
on earth which is what he wants and it's in that home that he works and reaches out to
others, so I also felt such pains because men were to be chastised that it seems that I
myself was to suffer not them, even more it seemed to me that if I could it would have
been more bearable for me to suffer all of the chastisements than to see others suffer,
see her love for her neighbour, now we know with regard to our family if you're a parent
and seeing a child really suffer you prefer to go through it yourself and see the child
helplessly suffer wouldn't you, but she has that level of love for the human race and
that's what's going to drive her to suffer the pains of the crucifixion, so you're dealing
with a very high level of love of neighbour here, I tried to compassionate him now every
time the word compassionate comes you won't hear it from me, I tried to sympathise with
him that's the words we use, as much as I could and with all my heart I said to him
oh holy spous hold back the scourges which your justice has prepared, if the multiplicity
of the iniquities of men is great there is the immense sea of your blood in which you
can bury them, in this way your justice will be satisfied, I've put John 1145 there, John
1145, if you have nowhere to go and delight yourself she said coming to me I give you
all of my heart now that's exactly what he's looking for and it's Deuteronomy 6, Deuteronomy
6 4 to 10, now when you're dealing with the first four volumes Deuteronomy 6 4 to 10 is
all over the place, so you need to know the words I know you know them as soon as I say
them you'll recognise them, hero Israel the Lord your God is one Lord and you shall love
the Lord your God with all your heart, notice the all, all your soul, all your mind and
all your being, you see it's a little all, the problem with most of us who are not like
Louis is we love him with a bit of our hearts and a bit of our soul, a bit of our minds
and a bit of our, but if he's going to do great things through us we need to give him
the all and he says if you give me your all I give you my all and my answer to that is
who gets the best bargain, I do I'm not going to say no to that, so Deuteronomy 6 4 to 10
is fulfilled in a person living in the divine will, so I give you all of my heart she said
that you may somehow rest and delight in it, it's true that I am also a builder of vices
now she's exaggerating there, she's at a very high level, she really should be saying
I'm a weak human being, but you can purify me and make me what you want, but or please
placate yourself if the sacrifice of my life is necessary or how gladly I would make it
for you as long as I may see your own images spared, your own images now is first of all
Genesis 1 27, Genesis 1 27 and Romans 8 29, Genesis 1 27 says we were made in the image
of God and Romans 8 29 is that in redemption we are transformed into the image of the Son,
Jesus, now when Louisa talks to Jesus about your own images, when human beings are really
rotten and stinking as he has just said, he's looking at sort of that lot, you know what
I mean, she said no no no, they are your own images, they were made like you, so she has
immediately got around them to look at it from a completely different angle and she uses
this as a lever to make intercession for the human race, she's very clever, she knows exactly
what to do, she's, I don't know how she got at this stage, she was absolutely incredible
to me, so they are your own images she said they have to be spared and the Lord interrupting,
my book says my speaking, is that what you have, knock that out, he interrupted me, that's
it, interrupting me continued, here is exactly where I wanted you, now he has managed to get
her just very gently to come to this point, it's fantastic, if you offer yourself to
suffer he said no longer every now and then is up to now but continuously every day for
a certain length of time I will spare them, there's a new stage in her development as
a victim soul, so not every now and then but continuously, see how I will do it, I will
put you between my justice and the iniquities of the creatures, that's extremely important
that is Sam 10623, Sam 10623 it's called standing in the breach, very important and if you go
back to the book of Exodus for example they say that if Moses hadn't stood in the breach
the people would never have survived the experience of the wilderness but Moses all the time would
stand between them and God and would intercede for them and Moses would humble himself to
God all the time and come back with God's message to them, so I will put you between
my justice and the iniquities of creatures, now Saint Therese of Lysue died just before
Louisa started writing this and Therese had offered herself to divine mercy, now Louisa
is being asked to offer herself to divine justice which is a much harder vocation, now
Therese really did suffer but this is a much higher vocation to be asked to stand before
divine justice and when my justice sees itself full of iniquities to the point of not being
able to contain them and is forced to send thunderbolts of discourages in order to chastise
the creatures, the creatures means the human race and finding you in the middle instead
of striking them it'll strike you, you see the person standing in the middle takes the
punishment like that's Jesus on the cross or in the passion taking the punishment and
therefore setting us free, so it's an extraordinary love for humanity only in this way will I be
able to be content and sparing human beings otherwise no, so Louisa remained all confused
she said I didn't she didn't know what to say, my nature would do its part being frightened
and trembling but I saw that my good Jesus was waiting for an answer whether I would
accept or not, now Louisa said something very important there, her human nature is the same
as yours and mine, we run from suffering the moment you get a headache you say where's
the paracetamol you don't say how can I make reparation for the human race that is a grace
that comes to you eventually there are a number of people in the divine will groups at this
moment who are ill or suffering in various ways and the extraordinary thing is every
one of them is full of joy, every one of them has spontaneously said they're offering it
in reparation and substitution, it's a sure sign they're living in divine will but the
ordinary folks they'll run for the paracetamol, some of the rest of us don't have paracetamol
in the house, it's not useful anymore, souls are, I hope I will be throwing challenges
out here, souls are you got to start thinking differently, absolutely differently and have
the privilege that there will be souls in heaven because you didn't take the paracetamol
I'm just using that as an example, there could be other examples but it's really thrilling
to me that these people there's about five of them that I could name but I don't want
to name because of this and that's been the spontaneous reaction which I think is fantastic
so seeing myself almost forced to speak Louisa said I said to him, all my most divine spous
on one hand I would really, I'm ready to accept but how is it going to work with the confessor
she's worried about him having to come all the time, if he doesn't want to come every
once in a little while how can it be possible that he come every day, free me from this
cross, see it, cross, that's the thorn in the side, that the confessor is needed in order
to free me and then everything will be arranged between me and you and the Lord said to me,
go to the confessor and ask him for the obedience, if he wants you will tell him everything I
told you and you will follow whatever he says, see it will not be only for the good of creatures
that I want these continuous sufferings but also for your good, in other words she will
grow hugely in sanctity very fast.
In this state of sufferings I will purify your soul thoroughly, now this woman is living
in a very high state of union but you see none of us have any inkling of what the purity
of God is like and to get very close to God all of us need horrendous amount of purification.
So if you're going to heaven on cushions get worried, if you're having trials and difficulties
the Lord is purifying you but if you're getting absolutely nothing and everything is going
your way and nothing opposes you or anything I'd be really worried because all of us have
to have our souls thoroughly purified in such a way as to dispose you to form a mystical
marriage with me and after this I will make the last transformation in such a way that
both of us will become like two candles placed on the fire, one is transformed into the other
and they become one, now if you put two candles on the fire you will not be able to separate
the different wactes.
The only way you'd know you had two candles because both of them were melt is that if
one of them was purple and the other one was white did you actually see the mixture of
the colours that's the only way you'd know.
So one will be transformed into the other and they will become one beside that you should
put John 14 21, you and me and I in you both completely one.
In this way I will transform myself in you and you will remain crucified with me Galatians
524, I'm crucified with Christ.
Would you not be happy if you could say the bridegroom is crucified but the bride is also
crucified?
Ah yes there's nothing that renders me dissimilar to him.
So when I was able to speak to the confessor Louisa said I told him everything that the
Lord had told me and since the Lord had said to me the words for a certain given time,
this is wonderful because it takes people ages and a lot of experience before they actually
know what God is saying to them and so Louisa gives the the the priests the impression that
a certain given time is a certain given time and then you'll hear very shortly that she
was 12 years in bed that's not a certain given time.
Without notifying me of the exact time during which I was to suffer continuously, I took
it to be about 40 days more or less in other words a Lenten period and now it has been twelve
years since I continued to be in bed.
May God be always blessed, may his inscrutable judgments be always adored and there is a
very important statement that when mysteries are happening in our lives instead of going
into a tizzy instead of rationalizing the whole thing that we would just simply adore
God's dispositions for us.
That's Romans 1133 that we literally adore his ways.
I believe that if the blessed Lord had made me understand clearly the length of time I
was to be in bed and as she's writing this she has no idea that she's going to spend
64 years in bed if she knew that she couldn't do it at all and this is the the great mercy
of God that he shows us life just one day at a time and why it is so wrong for people
to go to fortune tellers and all the rest of it because if for example a fortune teller
told you you'll have a car accident in a week what would you do for God in that week
you might do nothing you might just give up and you might take it as a fatalistic statement
many people allow their lives to be guided by these false prophets and very dangerous
things but the Lord in his great mercy gives you life in 24 hour doses and the amazing
thing is you can take it in 24 hour doses but if you look back over a long period of
suffering you say I couldn't have gone through that if I knew the length that's the same
with with Louisa my nature would have been frightened very much and would hardly have
submitted to it already I remember that I have always been resigned at that time I did
not know the preciousness of the cross that's another very important revelation she's going
to get suffering is one thing but the preciousness of the cross and the power of it is quite
another matter all together as the Lord made me know during the course of those twelve
years nor would the confessor have adapted to give me the obedience if he had known because
I mean how could a priest give you a permission to sit in a bed when you're in the whole of
your health the only illness Louisa ever had was the pneumonia from which she died so I
said to the confessor that the Lord wanted to give me the obedience to remain in continuous
suffering for about 40 days and I told him all the rest to my surprise because I thought
it was impossible the confessor told me that if it really was the will of God he would
give me the obedience now here's the priest beginning to receive big grace and enlightenment
from the Lord because he said in reality it wasn't that he couldn't come but it was
rather a bit of human respect now there you have the priest confessing to Louisa that he
could come but he was afraid of what everybody else would say to him my soul rejoiced very
much that I would be able to make the Lord content and therefore have human being spared
but my nature was very much afflicted in receiving this obedience so much so that for a few days
I was very saddened in other words who what teenager wants to sit in a bed doing nothing
I mean it's the first thing you hear from a kid as soon as they are running around the
place I'm bored I'm bored they need to be occupied so she actually suffered very much
from it my soul also was affected very much thinking that I was to remain for such a long
time without being able to receive Jesus in the sacrament now in these writings that
sacrament means holy communion and you just need to make sure you write it down that it's
not misunderstood you would get the impression that there wasn't six other sacraments and
so the thing that's worrying her is she won't get mass and she won't get holy communion
eventually of course they will put a little altar in her room and she'll have mass in
her room at times I would feel a war or so very fierce within me that I myself did not
know what had happened to me the devil too would add many things but my good Jesus put
a remedy to everything and this is how he did it now all of a sudden there is a break
in the story we're not going to pick up this story for quite a few pages because the priest
has intervened and the priest has suddenly realized that this woman is receiving different
types of communication from God and so he asks her to write out for him the different
ways in which God communicates with her so I wanted to put a heading over the next bit
the ways in which the Lord spoke to Louisa the ways in which the Lord spoke to Louisa
and when we're finished that then we'll go back to the story again so by order of the
current confessor I move on to speak about something else I will obey in manifesting
the various ways in which the Lord has spoken to me this wonderful teaching now it seems
to me that the ways in which the Lord has spoken to me are four and notice how clear
she is but these four ways of Jesus speaking she says communication I think is the better
word the four ways of Jesus communication are very different from inspirations the inspirations
are normal for everybody so number one the first way is when the soul goes out of herself
however first I want to explain a little bit better about the going out of myself it happens
in two ways this is the out of the body experience now and I have a query I can't give you an
absolute answer is this the flight of the spirit that John of the cross speaks about
I just haven't come to an absolute conclusion about it it happens in two ways the first
is instantaneous almost in a flash and it's so sudden that it seemed to me that the body
would lift a little that's levitation I would lift a little bit from the bed in order to
follow the soul and then it would stay there and it seemed to me that the body would remain
as dead while the soul would follow Jesus walking throughout the whole universe watch
this the earth the air the seas the mountains purgatory heaven and many times he showed me
the place where I would be after I die she was taken to heaven and everywhere she was
also taken to hell at one point the other way then is for the soul to go out is more
quiet so we would call this ecstasy it seems that the body dozes off insensibly and remains
as though petrified at the presence of Jesus Christ however the soul remains within the
body hence no flight of the spirit you see why I'm bringing that subject in and the body
no longer feels anything of external things even if all the universe turned it upside
down even if they burnt me up and reduced me to pieces the person is not available to
the body in this ecstatic state you see this from the the children at Gadubandal as well
that was quite clear wasn't it these two ways are so different of going out of myself that
I have noticed sensibly because in the first way having to obey the confessor when he would
come to wake me up I would see him from the place where Jesus would lead me and this is
one of the funny things that you're going to be reading funny as in smiling in these
early volumes where Luisa will be in and out of the body experience in the Lord she won't
want to come back and the Lord will say if there's your confessor he's coming for you
and she will see the confessor and she's got to get back into the body before the confessor
gets to the bed otherwise she hasn't obeyed and you have this tussle going on it's actually
quite funny the relationship between Luisa and Jesus is absolutely wonderful it's very
real and the Lord is teaching us all through it that he is genuinely relating to us as
a real person it's just we don't see him but everything is real so I would see the
the priest from the place where Jesus would lead me that is from the ends of the earth
imagine that from the air or from the mountains or the sea or purgatory or even heaven itself
and I want to stop there for a second this woman has to make a desperate sacrifice of
herself to sit in a bed for 64 years now human nature couldn't endure that so what is the
Lord to give her out of the body experience so she's traveling the earth and now into
traveling through the stars and going to heaven and purgatory and everything else that is
the balance we have to have balance you know and Padre Pio had by location you know that
don't you and his community used to tease him and say you're the only one who get around
obedience and the rest of us have to ask permission to go places but you just go anyway
out of my body is obeying the body stays there you know but it's just I just want to
point out that the balance is actually very essential for her psychological survival you
have to have balance we have to have light and darkness and you have to have day and
night and you have to have things happening and all the rest of that that's absolutely
essential to our being you'll be told in the higher volumes that life is in the motion
so she needs the motion so even more it would seem to me that I would not have the time
to let the confessor find my soul in the body and therefore I'd not be able to obey it seemed
that so far away as I was with my soul I say it seemed that I would bustle about and become
all anxious and worried that I mightn't be able to get myself and to be found there for
the confessor on time that's the bit I was saying to you and therefore I wouldn't be
able to obey however I confess that I've always been there on time God is never in a hurry
but he's always on time and it seems to me that my soul would enter the body just before
you have to you need to add in the word just just before the confessor would begin to give
media obedience to wake up in other words at the last possible second that's why the English
requires the word just before I'll just finish this a little bit we won't go on to number
two even more I tell you the truth many times from afar I could see the confessor coming
but in order not to leave Jesus it seemed that I would not be thinking that the confessor
was coming but then Jesus himself would hurry me to return with the soul into my body so
as to be able to obey the confessor and then I would feel great reluctance about leaving
Jesus and what obedience would win and upon leaving Jesus he himself either kissed me
or embraced me or would do something else to take leave of me in other words is a real
relationship and I upon leaving my dear Jesus would say to him I go to the confessor but
you my good Jesus come back soon as soon as the confessor goes away she cannot endure
being without him and the only thing that I say to people in volume one is this reminds
me of a young couple in love and the boy has just gone home you know and the girl phones
and before he gets into the car he just can't be without each other so she's now going
to talk about intellectual dialogue but I might leave that next week so I think we should
stop there.